after july first and before
election day in a presidential election
year
only four times in the history of this
country has a supreme court vacancy
arisen within four months
of a presidential election the next
number i think is very
important to remember and that number is
zero zero that's how many times these
vacancies
were filled in fact similar to this
vacancy
president lincoln had a senate majority
when a vacancy arose
just weeks before election day in 1864.
and what did he do he chose to wait
president lincoln thought nominating a
justice so close to an election
would delegitimize our institutions and
harm the republic that
he was fighting so hard to preserve
that's the precedent that president
trump and senate republicans have
disregarded
as they quickly plotted to fill the seat
just hours
if not minutes after justice ginberg
ginsburg's passing in addition to
breaking with this historical precedent
republicans are also jamming through
their nomination
in the middle of a pandemic that is
gripping
our country instead of prioritizing
michigan
first responders small businesses
workers
teachers and families and health care
professionals that are
still suffering through the effects of
the coronavirus pandemic
senate republicans and the president are
instead laser focused on jamming through
a supreme court nominee
for a lifetime appointment
this is more than just political
gamesmanship
this nominee will significantly impact
the lives of michiganders and
folks all across our country we know
that the supreme court
is set to shortly consider a case that
has
far-reaching ramifications for people's
health care
the trump administration is arguing in
court that the affordable care act
should be overturned in a case that will
come before the supreme court
in november just seven days after
election day if the trump administration
gets its way
in this lawsuit we could go back to the
days when
insurance companies once again call the
shots on
people's health care over 4 million
michiganders with pre-existing health
care conditions
could be denied coverage seniors could
be charged more
for prescription drugs lifetime and
annual limits on coverage
could make costs unaffordable and as a
result
force families into bankruptcy
before the passage of the affordable
care act medical debt was the number one
reason
for personal bankruptcy people faced
financial devastation
simply because they got sick
women could again be charged more for
being a woman
because a potential pregnancy is a
pre-existing condition we have come
way too far to be turning the clock
backwards
for the trump administration to be
pushing this lawsuit is reckless
and dangerous especially during the
worst
public health and economic crisis in
generations
but that's not all that's at stake
a woman's right to make her own health
care decisions and reproductive freedom
is at stake workers rights against
corporate special interests
are at stake environmental justice
is at stake access to the ballot box
is at stake attempts to end the
corrosive effect of money in campaigns
and elections
is at stake and lgbtq
rights are at stake those are just some
of the the many issues
that a supreme court justice with a
lifetime appointment
will be ruling on for decades to come
judge amy coney barrett's nomination has
extremely
far reaching consequences
we are just a few days from election day
already over two million michiganders
have voted and many more are voting as
i speak here today with all that's at
stake
michiganders deserve a say in who
nominates and confirms the next justice
to our nation's
highest court and the fact that
michiganders are being denied this
opportunity is simply unacceptable
therefore i cannot support this
nomination process
it should wait until a new president and
senate take office following an election
to take place
in only a few days so for this reason
and many others i will
not be voting for judge barrett's
confirmation
and will cast a no vote so mr
president you know here we are instead
of bringing folks
together to find common ground on
coronavirus relief
our country is being forced to go
through a divisive
supreme court nomination process
it simply did not have to be this way
i continue to stand ready to roll up my
sleeves and
put together a comprehensive bipartisan
and meaningful covid relief package
ask any michigander what they're worried
about today and you're going to get the
same answers from them
they're worried about being able to put
food on the table or
a roof over their head they're worried
about getting or
keeping a job to support their families
they're worried about catching a virus
that has killed over 7
000 of their fellow michiganders at over
220
000 people all across our nation
they are worried if they survive a covet
infection
it will compromise their health for the
rest of their lives
they will have a pre-existing condition
so i ask why isn't this pandemic the
senate's top priority right now
when we passed the cares act we came
together we put politics aside and
passed a real comprehensive package that
helped keep millions of people
stay afloat we need to summon that
spirit again
michiganders are counting on us
americans across
this country are counting on us
mr president i implore my colleagues to
drop what we are doing
and let's come together and pass a
meaningful bipartisan
covet relief package and let's get that
done
now mr president i yield
mr president the senator from new mexico
mr president i rise today
as more than 220
000 americans are dead
from the coronavirus there are more than
four million fewer jobs
than when donald trump took office
we are still squarely in the middle of
this pandemic
and an economic crisis the likes of
which we have not seen since the great
depression
in recent weeks cases of the coronavirus
have risen dramatically in
my home state of new mexico and frankly
across the entire
country everyone is rightly worried
about whether our schools and our child
care centers our small businesses can
acquire the resources
and the equipment they need to reopen
safely
we still don't have enough resources or
even a national plan for testing
and contact tracing much less for
treatments
and the eventual nationwide distribution
of a
fda-approved vaccine that would allow us
to finally get a handle
on this virus and if we don't pass
real economic relief in the coming weeks
many families in new mexico will face
desperate choices
between paying their bills keeping a
roof over their heads
or putting food on the table
and yet here we are
using valuable time on a supreme court
confirmation process that should have
never been taken up
before the election senate republicans
say they
aren't going to negotiate another
coronavirus relief package
they say it's more important to ram a
supreme court nominee
through a broken and nakedly political
process
than it is to help the people that we
were all
elected to serve clearly
nothing not even the lives and
livelihoods of the american people
will get in the way of their power grab
designed to reward their biggest donors
and the most extreme
interests well let me say this
clearly i disagree
there is still so much we need to do to
stop the spread of the coronavirus
and support families workers businesses
who are struggling
and rebuild our communities let's move
to
that urgent action but with senate
republicans refusing to do that let's
discuss
in real terms what they're doing
instead considering and confirming
supreme court nominees is one
of a senator's most solemn duties under
the constitution
we are supposed to take it seriously
deliberately
but senate republicans have thrown out
the rule book
it started when with nearly a full year
remaining in president obama's final
term
senate republicans refused to even hold
hearings
on merrick garland the nominee to
replace the late justice
antonin scalia then they dismantled the
rules that had
ensured that both parties would have a
seat at the table on
supreme court nominations and then they
bull rushed the vetting process for
justice kavanaugh's lifetime appointment
to the court
despite multiple credible allegations
of mis of sexual misconduct after
all of that i suppose it should have
come as no real surprise that majority
leader mcconnell waited
less than an hour after the announcement
of justice ruth
bader ginsburg's death to say that he
was going to push the envelope
even further so here we are
leader mcconnell and republicans are now
forcing the senate to rush through
another partisan supreme court
confirmation battle
mere weeks now mere days
before election day they are shamelessly
discarding their own precedence breaking
their
own rules abandoning their own
words and they are trampling
on the legacy of justice ruth vader
ginsburg before her death justice
ginsburg told her granddaughter that her
most fervent wish was that her seat
wouldn't be filled until after the next
president
is inaugurated justice ginsburg
served on our nation's highest court for
nearly three decades
and worked for decades before that to
move
our country's laws towards greater
equality
she understood that the american people
must trust
that the supreme court justices are
acting above
the partisan politics of the moment
the next presidential election is now
less than
two weeks away millions of americans
have already voted for their next
president
and their next senators i believe that
these americans deserve
a voice in this process
in the words of majority leader
mcconnell himself as reported in the
washington post on february 18
2016 quote
given that we are in the midst of a
presidential election process
the american people should seize the
opportunity to weigh
in on whom they trust to nominate the
next person
for a lifetime appointment to the
supreme court
the senate should follow that precedent
and should allow
voters to decide who should fill this
supreme court seat so what has changed
for majority leader mcconnell
well in the last decade the court has
made
razor thin five to four rulings
on women's rights on lgbtq rights
on workers rights immigration voting
rights civil rights climate change
and much else now my
republican colleagues will say that
these decisions were made by
activist judges and that all they want
are judges who will call balls and
strikes
what but what they really want
are judges who will make those calls
consistently biased
towards wealth and power rather than
towards
people for all the talk of activist
judges
it is my republican colleagues who are
right now attempting to add one whopper
of an
activist to the supreme court
next month the supreme court will take
up president trump's case
to eliminate the affordable care act
in its entirety
that's right in the middle of this
pandemic
that has now killed more than 220
000 americans and infected millions more
the supreme court is taking up a case
that could eliminate
health care coverage for millions of
americans
now judge barrett refused to answer
questions about the affordable care act
during her confirmation hearings
last week but her views
on the health care law are clear and
they are exposed
in the public record judge barrett has
repeatedly and publicly criticized the
affordable care act
she has said that the supreme court
should have already
invalidated it if senate republicans
have their way
she will have the opportunity to do just
that
what would it mean if the supreme court
overturns the affordable care act
it means bringing back discrimination
higher costs even outright denial
of coverage for more than 800 000 new
mexicans living with pre-existing
conditions
like heart disease diabetes
cancer and now covet 19.
i am particularly worried about what
this would mean
for the people in indian country who
have been disproportionately
impacted by this pandemic
new mexico tribal nations have
experienced heartbreaking losses
and health care resources in the tribal
communities have been
incredibly strained i have lost friends
and mentors in indian country and i know
others
who are still struggling to recover from
this virus
i can't even imagine how much worse this
situation could become
if the health coverage provided by the
affordable care act were ripped away
when we passed the affordable care act i
fought hard
to include a permanent reauthorization
liberal scholars and mainstream mental
rose scholars
put that commission together and have
them and do an analysis
of what any changes should take place
and how the court
functions how it's picked how that's how
it's picked
how long you stay in the court how long
whether or not for example there was a
put for an idea put forward by
one of the scholars out of colombia
saying that what you should do is you
go supreme court direction number years
then you go to a circuit court
and then someone from the circuit court
goes and spins it yeah
but there's all kinds of things but
here's what i think they have to do
i'm not a big fan of court packing i'm
not a big fan of saying we're just going
to add
x numbers but i'm going to listen
listen to all the ideas that because
it's become a serious question
going into the middle of the 21st
century
and a lot of scholars are considering
alternatives to
how we presently proceed and uh
and i'm going to ask him to report back
to me assuming i'm elected
uh in 180 days and uh
and we'll uh decide whether to do
anything but here's one thing
no questions for the pressure pain the
neck this guy alone
is always the first time to ask a
question
with you okay thank you but here's the
deal
here's the deal one of the things that
that is important
is that um
keep in mind although they're going to
vote on
we're going to please
because he's going to get remarked he'll
probably take a few questions so
all right yeah
oh
[Music]
oh
okay
how are you
i don't care
[Applause]
thank you
you
you
you
you